merci sa belle je voudrais moi aussi
remercier tout particulièrement jean
pierre raffarin qui pendant des années a
animé notre conseil national ce qui est
le rôle du président du conseil national
il l'a fait avec un souci de l'équité et
du respect des horaires il m'a indiqué
qu'il ne souhaitait plus continuer cette
forme
cette fonction c'est la raison de
l'élection
je me réjouis que nous ayons deux
candidats la période où les partis
politiques n'avaient pour les élections
qu'un seul candidat parce que c'était
pas des élections est terminée moi même
j'ai le plaisir d'être candidat aux
côtés bruno le maire que je salue et
d'hervé mariton un mouvement politique
moderne c'est un mouvement qui sait
choisir ses responsables et qui n'a pas
peur de la démocratie
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
allons maintenant donner pour le même
temps et par ordre alphabétique la
parole à michèle alliot marie que
j'appelle puis à luc chatel michel